[Music]
CHR
h
[Music]
Christian
in
[Music]
hello
everyone my name is
johnine we are delighted that you have
come to worship with us this evening
both in person and you guys online
welcome it is good to see you
and I just want you to know that you're
not only welcome here but you are
celebrated here so I have a few
announcements for you first of all we'd
love for you to come to hat Creek Burger
Company after the service today this is
our first Sunday meal that we have
together and it's at Highway 78 wood
Woodridge Parkway here in saxi and it's
right after the service it's a great
chance to connect connect and to meet
some folks I will be there so I will see
you when when you get there um also
there will be no Sunday service on May
the
26th we take two Sundays off every year
and may the 26 Memorial Day weekend is
one of them it gives our volunteers and
our staff a break so uh we'll start up
our normal Services then on Sunday June
the 2nd
we have a pride Booth I'm wearing my
colors okay everyone yeah so if you are
interested in being a loving and
welcoming
presence and being amongst a group of
people who have been hurt by the church
uh showing up then and like to volunteer
for a three-hour slot then scan the QR
code and come out sign up and um be in
our booth for the uh PR
uh Saturday June the 1st all right our
kids team woo we have a great kids Team
guys they are getting busy planning for
this year's summerama event it will be
Friday and Saturday June 21st and 22nd
so if you have kids going into
kindergarten or finishing sixth grade
that would like to come play learn and
grow in love for Jesus and others this
summer then then save those dates on
your calendar and be watching for more
information and signups in the coming
weeks all right now comes the time for
us to release the
busyness just quiet the
noise to to settle into our
bodies Our
Hearts our
minds to cross over the
threshold into the kingdom of
Silence
Stillness and
simplicity to cross over into a Sacred
Space a space for prayer
worship and
adoration a space to behold
Christ revelation of God heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find
you to mend your
[Music]
heart may we all come home
thank you
johnine would you guys quietly stand
up let's stay in that posture of just
openness settling
in and not trying to run away from what
we' carried into this space but instead
hold it openly and allow God to meet us
with whatever we're
[Music]
carrying come and Tear Down the Walls of
build up every wall I've built up every
wall I've built up cuz you
deserve every piece of my heart every
piece of my heart every piece of my
heart come and Tear Down the Walls I've
build up every wall I've build up every
wall I build up cuz you deserve every
piece of my heart every piece of my
heart every piece of My Heart Lord
I am trusting that you are a faithful
father and all that you have it is
good you're a generous Giver with love
like no other won't you come and Brak
through to me over and over and over
again I am bringing my heart to you with
open hands and closer and closer you
drawing me in as the depths of my heart
lay before you let's sing that again
over and over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
closer and closer you're drawing me in
as the depths of my heart lay before you
again
oh you
[Music]
[Applause]
deserve come and Tear Down the Walls I
buil up every wall I buil up every wall
I build up cuz you deserve every piece
of my heart every piece of my heart
every piece of my heart come Tear Down
the Walls I built up every wall I buil
up every wall I buil up cuz you deserve
every piece of my heart every piece of
my heart every piece of My Heart
Lord I am trusting that you are
faithful father all that you have is
good you're aen is g with love like no
other won't you come and breakr to me
over and over over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
closer and closer you drawing me in as
the dance of my heart lay before you
again over and over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open hand
closer and closer you drawing me in as
the depths of my heart lay before you
again
[Music]
let's sing
come come Tear Down the Walls of build
up every wall of buil up every wall of
buil up you deserve every piece of my
heart every piece of my heart every
piece
of my
[Music]
heart all right I'm going to dismiss you
kids to go to your
classrooms thank you again to our
amazing kids ministry team who's going
to be serving them
tonight blessings on you guys
and we are going to transition into the
prayers of the people um if this is your
first night with us we kind of carve out
this space in our service every week for
us to be honest and share the things
that we're carrying into this space um
the things that are heavy on our hearts
so we're going to read this prayer aloud
together and then we will leave some
space for you to speak out loud a name
or a situation that um that you have on
your heart tonight and then we'll wrap
up the prayer at the end together again
so you guys can follow along the
screen Jesus for this city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to
you for the Good Earth that you have
given us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you for the old
and the sick for the Widow and orphan
for the injured and suffering we pray to
you for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experienced ing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
you Angelina
[Music]
k for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and Light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
[Music]
amen are you hurting and broken Within
overwhelmed by the weight of your
sin Jesus is
Calling have you come to the end of
yourself do you thirst for a Dream from
the
whale Jesus is
Calling oh come to
the
altar the father's arms are open wide
forgi was bought with the precious blood
of Jesus
[Music]
Christ leave behind your regrets and
mistakes come to there's no reason to
wait Jesus is
Calling bring your sorrow and TR them
for
Joy From the Ashes a new life is
born Jesus is
[Music]
Calling oh
come to the
altar the father's arms are open wide
forgi was B with the precious blood of
Jesus
Christ come
to the
altar the father's arms are
rolling for
foress was bought with the precious
blood of Jesus
[Music]
Christ So What A Savior
isn't he
wonderful sing
Hallelujah Christ is
[Music]
risen bow down
before
him for he is
Lord sing hallelu
Christ
[Music]
Isis Oh What A Savior oh what a
saor isn't he
wonderful sing
Hallelujah Christ is
RIS bow down before him
for he is Lord
of sing
Hallelujah Christ is
risen yeah he loves us Oh How He Loves
Us Oh How He Loves Us oh how he
loves yeah he loves us Oh How He Loves
Us Oh How He
Loves oh how
he so what a
saor is he want
[Music]
sing
Hallelujah Christ
[Music]
Isis bow down before
him for he is Bor of all sing
Hallelujah Christ is risen
[Music]
So What A
Savior isn't he
wonderful sing
Hallelujah Christ is
risen bow down
before
him he is Lord of all
sing
Hallelujah Christ is
[Music]
risen bury a cross as you wa
for the
crown tell the world of the Trey found
[Music]
God of
creation there at the start before the
beginning
[Music]
of with no point of
reference you spoke to the dark
and fleshed Out The Wonder of
light and as you
speak 100 billion galaxies are
born in the vapor of your breath the
planet form
if the stars were made to worship so
alive I can see your heart in everything
you
made every buring Star a signal fire of
Grace if creation sings your Praises so
alive
[Music]
prise you don't speak in vain Sy empty
your
voice for once you have spoken
Nature and Science follow the sound of
your
[Music]
voice and as you
speak the 100 billion creatures catch
your
breath evolving in pursuit of what you
said if it all reveals your nature so
[Music]
alive I can see your heart and
everything you
say every paint is a can
of creation still oys you so alive
[Music]
if the stars were made to worship so
will
I if the mountains bow in reverence so
so will
I if the O Roar your great so will
I for if everything exists to lift you
high so Al liive if the wind goes where
you send it so
Al if the rocks cry out inside and so
will I
if the S of all our praise is still fall
sh then we'll sing again 100 billion
[Music]
times God of salvation
you chase down my heart through all of
my failure and
pride on a hill you
created the light of the world abandon
in darkness to
die and as you speak
billion failures
[Music]
disappear where you lost your life so I
could find it
here if you left the grave behind you so
alive I can see your heart and
everything you've
done every part designed and work of
heart
if you gladly chose surrender so Al
I I can see your heart a billi
different every precious one child you D
to if you gave your life to love them
soike like you you would again a 100
billion
[Music]
times but what measure could amount to
your
desire you're the one who never leaves
the one behind
yes God you've chosen us as your
children regardless of our
failures no matter the mistakes we've
made God you've loved
us you've come after
us you've sought us out you've made
space for us
you've called us by
[Music]
name God tonight we want to
connect with that
heart the one who's loved us through it
all the one who seen the shame and the
pain and the destruction
the one who knows our
sins and still loves
us still sees
us still knows the good that you
created still offers us
hope still transforms us and makes us
new each day
we love
you because you have first loved
us would we come to know that love in a
new way
tonight would it change the way that we
think the way we see ourselves the way
we interact with our world
let it do a good work in our
hearts in Jesus name
amen would you guys greet the people
around you and say hello and then Brett
will get a started on our message
Grace and peace it is uh so good to be
with you here and uh yeah just welcome
welcome to the table and uh it's a a joy
to welcome uh as well those join us
online and uh especially anyone here
tonight uh who is new um I just yeah I'm
really really glad that you're here and
I hope you find just a a sense like a a
god of compassion um a Christ of love a
community of Welcome uh here in this
space so we're really glad that you're
here and uh oh I also want to do a quick
mention any um
teachers anyone in our education system
teach you would you like I'm going to do
it would you do a little stand up
because it is Teacher Appreciation
Week give them a
hand
yes so grateful for our
teachers hard
job cuz I know my kids I know them so I
can't imagine just 30 of them in a room
just like oh my L it's a lot um so we
are uh we're in a season of The Church
calendar right now known as Easter tide
and uh in the same way we spent kind of
a season preparing for uh the day of the
Cross Good Friday um now on the backside
of Easter we spend a day um just
basically rejoicing over Easter I
shouldn't say day but a whole season uh
just celebrating uh Resurrection Life
and so with that in mind the uh the
series that we're in right now is titled
practicing resurrection and we're just
kind of looking at the book of Acts and
following how the early church kind of
lived into Resurrection Life and and
what all that entailed and so with that
in mind the title of my message tonight
is deformed and
reformed deformed and reformed you'll
notice uh the the the story we're in
this week is it's sort of it's similar
to the one we were in last week if you
were here last week that was the story
of the Ethiopian unic and we kind of
Drew out these themes of like the kind
of expanding inclusive love of God you
know across boundaries of you know
ethnicity and and sexuality and gender
and all that um this week the story it
could be similar because it's another
story of Gentile inclusion this is like
a major theme in the book of Acts um but
what I want to do is kind of expand you
could say everything we talked about
last week is still included in what I'm
getting at but I want to kind of open it
up and hopefully make it kind of a
little bit more broadly applicable
uh so hopefully that that kind of comes
out as we get into this so this is acts
10:
44-48 while Peter was still speaking
these words the Holy Spirit came on all
who heard the message the circumcised
believers who had come with Peter that
would be like the Jewish um his
contingent his his group there uh with
Peter we absolutely astonished that the
gift of the Holy Spirit had been poured
out even on Gentiles for they heard them
speaking in tongues and praising God
then Peter said surely no one can stand
in the way of their being baptized with
water they've received the Holy Spirit
just as we have so he ordered that they
be baptized in the name of Jesus Christ
then they asked Peter to stay with them
for a few days so you might be able to
tell that is like the very end of a
story and so what I want to do is go
backwards a little bit and um unpack
like what what led up to this moment
and so there was uh this this man this
um Roman
Centurion this Gentile man named
Cornelius and he was a man who's
described in the text as being very um
very religious in a good sense he was um
uh upright he cared for the poor he was
generous with his money and was a man of
prayer so uh one day he receives this
Angelic vision and the angel said to him
these words so this is like you know
rewind 40 verses this is now verse four
of the same chapter your prayers and
your gifts to the poor have come up as a
memorial offering before God now send
men to japa to bring back a man named
Simon who is called
Peter so Cornelius does this sends this
this group of men from his household uh
from the town he lives in cesaria uh
down to japa this is a 32 Mile Journey
now what you need to understand
is right as those men kind of they make
that Journey probably through the night
the the next day Peter uh this is like
the famous you know Apostle Peter um who
you know denied Christ and all that but
also is now like leading the church in
Jerusalem is like a you know major
leader um so he's in this house there in
japa he's saying his kind of afternoon
prayers uh when suddenly he receives his
own Angelic Vision or I guess in this
sense it was more uh well at first he
just hears a voice and and then he sees
this vision and it's all manner of like
forf footed beasts and reptiles and
birds and then Peter uh hears these
these words get up Peter kill and
eat which if you're familiar with
Judaism this would be a big no no you
know it's like birds reptiles like not
Kosher and so he reacts like viscerally
to this he says surely not Lord I have
never eaten anything unclean in my whole
life and uh the voice responds with this
this kind of turn a phrase which will
become important later in the story uh
and it's more than just about animals um
he says this do not call anything
unclean that I have made
clean don't call anything unclean that I
have made clean the vision then repeats
itself three times probably for emphasis
like get it you get it Peter you got
this right he's he's struggling with
this so just then there's a knock knock
knock at the door who is it it's the men
right it's this this contingent from
cornelius's house so the voice says to
Peter like go downstairs there's going
to be a group of men don't hesitate go
with them uh back to cesaria so he he
does this him and his a group of friends
with Peter they they all travel now back
another 32m Journey uh they get there
and now this is like a it's a big moment
just it's for big moment for Peter it's
a big moment in kind of in Christian
history because here's Peter you know
the Orthodox Jew that he is that that
also though believing in Jesus as
Messiah you know but still you know very
Orthodox and he's standing there at the
prec
of this doorway this to this Gentile
household this this
unclean kind of community and Cornelius
has like gathered like all of his
friends and family I mean everyone's
there you know so there Peter stands I'm
just imagining like that moment for him
so he's standing there at the doorway
and this is he he utters these words
this is it's it's kind of interesting so
he says this he he said to them you are
all well aware
that it is against our law for a Jew to
associate with or visit a
gentile it's a kind of awkward opening
you know like hello everyone you know I
shouldn't be
here I'm not even sure I should be here
yeah that's kind of this the
subtext uh
so I now this next part you know was it
with a sense of all and wonder was it
kind of begrudging we don't totally know
because of course it's it's text on a
page we can't you know see his body
language and such I I wonder how he said
these next words uh but he he he says
this but God has shown me you can see
where he's connecting the ideas but God
has shown me that I should not call
anyone impure or
unclean and see where he kind of Drew
the the connection like he knows like oh
wow this is like a bigger thing than
even just eating kosher or not Kosher
you know whatever uh now it's
interesting his language there you know
God has shown me it's not I now believe
you know like I have the conviction that
this is the truth of the Lord you know
like he's not preaching a sermon yet
like he's just you know it's no you ever
been there in that moment where it's
you're still in the phase of God has
shown me God is is showing me it's
sinking in I'm getting it I'm in the
process I don't totally get it but I'm
starting to get you know it's kind of
that that phase that's where he is so
they then Express that they're hungry to
receive the message uh so he um to which
he replies again it seems with more than
a little shock kind of he's still it's
like all sinking in he says I now
realize how true it is that God does not
show favoritism but accepts from every
nation the one who fears him and does
what is Right hean pres to tell them all
about Jesus Life Death Resurrection
ascension all of that uh
and then that's that kind of Catches Us
up to verse 44 the the opening passage
we read where the the Holy Spirit kind
of falls on them they're like speaking
in tongues and it's you know and and
even that again he's the the people
among them definitely the Jewish
contingent with Peter is like they're
shocked the text says like oh my gosh
the holy spirit's even poured out on
those people you know it's this whole
moment and uh then Peter himself seems a
little you know more than a little
astonished says okay well what can we do
like go go ahead and baptize them
obviously they've they've received the
Holy
Spirit uh now here's what I want you to
notice like on the one hand uh Peter's
pretty clearly like he's obedient you
know like at every step of the way
there's there's no like well maybe
except in that opening Vision surely not
Lord you know but outside of that like
he's he's doing the thing you know what
I mean God tells what you and he's doing
it uh but are you picking up on the fact
that
this is far from a kind of confident I
just do whatever God said you know like
at every step of the way right from the
vision and the surely not Lord to the
hesitating on the precipice of
cornelius's Doorway to the kind of shock
at oh my gosh it apparently God does not
show favoritism to uh the surprise over
the signs of the holy spirit's presence
like just over and over I I kind of love
this because I think we often imagine
sort of you know Biblical characters so
to speak as I don't know these people
have just faith and they just got it and
you know of course the more you read the
Bible the more you know they're just
people like just like us and so they're
they have their own you know struggles
and Journeys so okay so what does this
mean kind of for for us our own moment
uh Christian
discipleship is the very messy
process of of God kind of reforming
Within in each and every one of us what
has been
deformed kind of what I have in mind
here is like so much of of learning this
faithfulness to Jesus it's not just
about adding things it's not just about
learning new rhythms and such so that
can be part of it a huge I mean honestly
the farther I have this journey the more
it seems to me that it is precisely
about unlearning
de
learning does that make sense like it's
like in other words it's not just adding
more which is often how we think of so
much of discipleship I just need to do
more I need more you know I mean longer
times of whatever more scripture more
truth more preaching more this more that
um and that can be helpful that's it's
good it's good but can you see that so
much of the journey is like it's this
process
of of um I just have so much that is
kind of De and disformed within me and I
need God to set my mind
right like even if as I kind of look out
at the world it kind of feels like
everyone's kind of crazy I don't know
like we're all just GNA lose you know
what I mean and so it makes sense that
to fall more in love with God to follow
Christ in this beautiful way it would be
this process of like bringing us back to
sanity and in other words it's that that
that
reforming healing what has been deformed
I like this language of kind of formed
as opposed to learned learned is it it
strikes me as a little bit heady you
know I mean kind of intellectual like I
learning I need to learn the things and
unlearn the bad things and learn the
right things which can kind of make it
sound like a lot of you know books or
something which to be clear I think
education such can help but I'm I like
the word for because it's much more like
holistic you know this is like I mean
think of even in Peter's case you know
it's this kind of prayerful experience
of God leading him to like make a
32-mile journey meet with people talk to
them I mean this is like a full bodied
relational kind of experience where
Peter is being like what is deformed
within Peter is getting like
reformed and and uh this of course like
becomes a kind of theme of the book of
Acts I sort of hinted at this last week
too
where you might say that it's like God
is um well let me back up let me kind of
give an example of what I mean by
deformed before I launch into this thing
about God so let me name this um what do
I mean by deformed we all have old
assumptions prejudices storylines pet
theologies wounds codependencies
addictions coping mechanisms and I could
just just keep going with comma comma
comma you know I mean like we just here
all night you know struggles whatever uh
we like we all have this that that
neuron by
neuron must be Unwound and undone healed
and made
whole and so that's the process now how
does this happen this is where I want to
get to God like many of us I think
because Church in religion is often
quite stuck in the past so to speak um
we often think of God as sort of stuck
in the past you know like not exactly on
the Vanguard of what is fresh and new
and challenging you know and I think
church I don't necessarily you know I
mean like just the brand Church
reputation church I'm not thinking like
The Cutting Edge you know and because of
this we imagine this with God you know
God's sort of It kind of comes back to
even image of God like old white man
beard you know stuck in the path like
that's our image whatever and actually
the image you get from the book of Acts
is God is always out in front of
us ahead of us calling us beckoning us
inviting us into what is fresh and new
like what healing looks like for you
like God already knows it and is like
come
on come on like are you with me are you
with me and what's the invitation for us
I mean really honestly all we have to do
it's it's simple but it's not easy all
we have to do is say like
Peter yes like that's a bit that's you
know like okay
I'll I'll go with this I'll roll with
this but it is it takes tremendous
courage doesn't it like tremendous
courage to to go with God into these
things it reminded me of a a little
quote from friederick nii whose
philosophy I mostly hate but uh this
quote is good this quote it's he's I
mean he's a fantastic writer amazing one
of the great philosophical writers but
oh that I don't like it okay but this
quote is good all right so he says this
the strength of a person's Spirit would
then be measured by how much truth they
could
tolerate or more precisely to what
extent they need to have it diluted
disguised sweetened muted and
falsified woo ni is preaching there I
love that idea of like oh it's a good
question how much truth can I
take like I like to think oh yeah no no
I'm down I'm ready just just bring it on
L you know but then I'm kind of like oh
wait wait wait Slow Down slow down let
me think about you know like like the TR
how much how clearly am I really up for
seeing
myself I'd like to think I'm all on
board but I don't know you know or how
how much do I really want to see like
the truth the reality of my most key
relationships like I want to know the
truth of exactly how I'm coming across
how that how healthful or unhealthful
that is like I'm I'm up for it you know
like yikes anyone else like a little
little hesitant there H how much truth
are we really open to along these same
lines back during Advent I mentioned
this quote from Richard Roar which is
kind of uses a little more Christian
language to say much the the same thing
he he says this the real meaning of
repentance is seing what you've chosen
not to
see I like that CU it's not seeing what
you've never seen
before you know which that that can
happen but it's more seeing what you've
chosen not to see the truth that you're
like huh you know like there's some part
of your subconscious that knows there's
some part of you that knows but you
don't want to know that you know
you know what I mean like it's this it's
this weird I mean humans are weird
admittedly we're all very bizarre and we
can do this uh we we kind of Disconnect
and
separate I was um speaking recently with
a
friend and uh he just went through some
just tremendous uh abuse like childhood
um physical abuse at the hands of his
parents and uh he's sharing these
stories with me you know and I'm just oh
my gosh
um but it was it was interesting like a
I could see how even in his life today
like all that still kind of playing out
you know it's like certain things in our
life just kind of Mark us very
powerfully and even as we kind of grow
and emerge heal from the wounds you know
and we become different like there there
can be a healing but it's not like it it
doesn't wipe away the past you know I
mean it doesn't just yeah make it
invisible or something and you can kind
of see that he he carries these things
you know um but he was telling me the
the story of well he described his
parents and he said um he said you know
my parents they're like they were really
strange people he said uh they kind of
had this ability to like live in their
own
fantasy like it was like their vision of
reality they would just weave
stories about situations and people and
their lives and who they were and who
others were and like and and if anyone
in their life kind of contradicted that
pushed back on that oh he said they were
kicked out like it was just the boot for
them like nope not dealing with
you and what what's going on there like
it it struck me that like really
thinking of ni's quote really healthy
relationships have a large capacity for
what for
Truth for
reality very um mature people have a
large capacity for Truth for
reality and in this gentleman's case his
parents did
not they were living in their own dream
world he said that's why at age 18 He
said I would have left either way
because of the abuse and such
but he said they kicked me out because I
was unwilling to go along with their
delusions
anymore and he said that family system
had to you know hit the eject button on
me it's a it's a heavy truth but can you
see the the kind of reverse of that the
the Beauty and the goodness of embracing
reality like embracing the thing God's
inviting us into like there's such
goodness and hope there we might kind of
sum it up by saying that our own
capacity for growth and Transfiguration
into the image of Christ is governed by
how much truth we can
tolerate like how willing are we to look
where we do not want to
look to hear what we do not want to hear
to maybe speak the hard truth that oh
some of you are very conflict avoidant
you know just oh I don't want to say it
I don't want to say it I just can't I
just can't do it you know just can't do
it and yet could it be that that's
precisely the area Christ is inviting
you to grow
into like whatever the thing is that
you're like so tempted to just avoid
like I just don't want to go there I
just don't want to go there I don't want
to talk about that see that acknowledge
that like that's where you know I mean I
just I come back to Peter's vision
surely not Lord surely not oh my gosh my
whole religious worldview is being
exploded right now you know and and I
just I wonder what is it for
you the surely not Lord like not that
thing not that area not that Dynamic not
that relationship not that like no you
know but it's precisely
there that like all of the good stuff
happens it's precisely there that God
just meets Us in in in God's grace you
just transforms us from the inside out
it's sort of those um the phrase I use
often is is like it's like God keeps
bringing us to these moments of either
break down or
breakr one or the other you know what I
mean and it's like we get to choose sort
of is it is it going to be the breakdown
or the
Breakthrough and and it's really about
our capacity to just say like Yes to God
like okay I'm trusting I'm
trusting now
um I I should mention it's easier of
course
to judge others you know to see where
they are falling short I think of even
Peter we kind of look at Peter you know
and just be like can you believe his
religious you know this ethnic religious
pride and such you know and just come on
man get over it you know but of course
so much harder for us right to like
acknowledge those things in our own
selves um now I should mention at this
point as I kind of close I can I realize
this can all sound a little bit intense
and perhaps Bleak and undesirable I
don't know maybe you're just like give
me my fantasies and
delusions I don't want this um so let me
give one final word in favor of this so
here's the upside you know if we're
willing to grow in this awareness and
face difficult truths about ourselves
and and I should say relationships and
the world and everything um we just
might become an elder rather than simply
growing old old my Elder here I'm not
thinking of you know like church
whatever I mean like we all we just we
just might grow
up you know and and then what that would
mean is we just might become a community
that actually like kind of grows older
and wiser instead of becoming a church
of old
infants nothing worse you ever known an
old infant oh nothing worse so you can
deal with an actual infant being an
infant or even a teen kind of being an
infant maybe even someone in their 20s
you know but at some point it's like
okay it's just the I mean someone's 70
and it's still all about them that you
know what I mean and they have no no
capacity for
truth no capacity for reality oh
painful so it's like in ways we're kind
of caught between a rock and a hard
place aren't we on the one hand we're
like no give me give me my fantasies and
delusions you know this is so this is
hard you know but on the other hand to
not do it to not say yes oh no that
comes with all of its you know its own
issues its own stuff so my my kind of
prayer for you all this week to uh
paraphrase the the writer Ken Wilbur is
uh may we all grow up and clean
up um so that we can or I should say we
maybe we wake up clean up and grow up up
that's his order so that we can show up
for God and one
another and that's my prayer may we be a
church of folks growing older and wiser
together not a church of infants in the
name of the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit
amen so as we uh as we come to the table
of the Lord tonight as we take in the
body of Christ in the bread the blood of
Christ in the wine may this be a moment
where maybe just like a little a little
moment for you to say yes in your own
heart and mind you know uh maybe may it
could be a symbol as you take in that
that that bread that cup that it's like
it's like your own little moment of yes
to whatever it is God's inviting
inviting you into so the way we'll take
this tonight we'll go um just row by row
starting here not at the front row two
will be our first row and we'll we kind
of work back from there and we'll just
form a line right here um we practice
what's called an open table so if you're
here tonight and you want to participate
regardless of you know denomination or
whatever if there's something you wants
to connect with with the Risen Christ
then you're you're welcome to
participate um in this time with us uh
you should know the red is wine the
white is grape juice and then finally
you can just partake just whenever you'd
like no one will lead you through the
exact moment some folks like to kneel
some folks like to return to their seat
some take it immediately so however you
like to partake you can so this is the
table not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him so
come you who have much
faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to follow and you who have
failed come
come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites
you and it's his will that those who
want to meet him should
meet
here come to the table
[Music]
for
we're going to close out with that verse
um from so will I again so if you guys
would stand with us as we sing that
together just kind of taking on the
heart of Christ and um wanting to follow
in the new work that he sometimes is
doing in us that can be so difficult to
grab on to but but our hearts let's
let's posture our hearts to want to
follow in his
ways God of
Salvation you chased them my heart
through all of my failure and
pride the hill you
created the light of the world abandoned
in darkness to
[Music]
die and as you
speak 100 billion failures
[Music]
disappear you lost your life so I could
find it
here if you left the grave behind you so
alive I can see your heart everything
done every part design and a work of
if you
CL surrender so will
I I can see your heart a billi different
ways every precious one a child you D
to if you gave your life to love them so
alive
like you would again 100 billion
[Music]
times but what measure could amount to
your
desire you're the one who never leaves
the one behind
[Music]
thank you all so much for joining us
this
evening if you're new I'd like to invite
you to fill out a card over there on the
table or scan the QR code that's on the
screen
above and that uh you can fill out a
visitor's card online what we'd like to
do is contact you um let you thank you
for joining us today answer any
questions that you might have uh my name
is johnine in case you forgot and if
you're in need of a hug or need prayer
or just anything come find me after the
service or you can find me at hat Creek
I'll be there and I'll be glad to visit
with
you here at the table we're also
committed to creating an inclusive
Christ centered community that touches
lives and a key component to that is
giving so I wanted to let you know that
my uh wife lesle and I you know often
what we do is we're inspired by someone
or something here a group of people and
so we might just give to a particular
cause and so if you'd like to join us in
that you may also scan the QR code and
give online or there's a little box over
there that you can drop your donation in
or you can go to the website at theable
tx.org and join us in that uh in that
giving and
now I'd like to send you into your week
with this blessing
you can hold out your hands in a posture
of receiving or just open up your hearts
to these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of God this is true
on your best day and it's true on your
worst day so as you go into your week
ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything else in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved that you are worthy
that you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
that you come in contact with be blessed
have a good week and I look forward to
seeing you in a little
while the stars were made to worship so
[Music]
alive theive